I couldn't be more pleased to join you
in today's celebration as we honor dr.
Jared L Cohen thank you in the naming of
this wonderful building as we will hear
from some of your most ardent admirers
Jerry this building embodies some of
your most personally meaningful
contributions to Carnegie Mellon which
given your long list of accomplishments
that says so very much recognition of
the accomplishments of Jerry as the
president of Carnegie Mellon the board
of trustees voted to name this building
the cone university center here we are
today to make this official it cures
Pollock and I are pleased to be here on
behalf of the trustees it's very fitting
that this building was selected to have
jerry's name because it is at the heart
of campus life over 16 years as
president jerry had an impact that every
aspect of campus life in this building
represents the sum total of activity
better than any other single place on
campus but thank you for all that you've
done for CMU you were the perfect choice
and a very special man thank you very
brave to not be more appropriate for
this building to be named for president
Jared Cohen under whose presidency there
was such explicit recognition of the
value of what Mike Murphy although
perhaps no one else that's called the
medic curriculum although Mike I always
like that term the student organizations
the internships the student service
activities recreational and athletic
activities study groups the pickup games
of basketball the lunches shared the
friendships made throughout Jerry 16
years as president he recognized the
need to continually improve the quality
of campus life both in Pittsburgh and I
might say around the world for faculty
staff and especially for students it's a
story that's been told by my friend and
colleague John Hannon associate dean of
student affairs that I would ask that he
joined me at the podium to share with
you this memory and to share with your
closest friends the university was
presented with the opportunity to build
out the unfinished lower level of this
building to include among other things a
recreation and game room one particular
feature that dr. Murphy was quite
insistent on including in the game room
was a shuffleboard table the problem
with shuffleboard tables is that they
must be constructed and delivered in one
unified piece namely a 30 foot long
object weighing 1,500 pounds dr. Murphy
charge Dean and I with finding 15
student volunteers of adequate
musculature to move the table into its
final resting place but I can assure you
that shortly after starting the process
of moving the table my 15 friends from
the football team realized they were in
for an experience far far more
challenging than any 30 day practice
held during lack nurse preseason camp we
quickly learned that we were being pwned
by the table blood sweat tears all were
clearly in play as we shared an unspoken
contemplation regarding whether we would
actually be able to be successful in
getting that table moved into place it
was at that exact moment while we were
in the process of a short eight-foot
advance of the table that I saw dr.
Cohen round the corner of the hallway we
were in as soon as he saw the agonized
look on all of our faces he hustled over
to the table whipped off his suit jacket
in a move that was half James Bond and
half Don Draper grabs a pre free portion
of the table and began assisting us in
our undertaking five awkward minutes
later we found ourselves setting the
table down in its final and current
resting place the students and I all
stared at each other and disbelief
partly because we had accomplished that
which it seemed unthinkable 50 yards ago
and partly because our university
president had been the game changer in
making it happen no one knew exactly
what to say except of course dr. Cohen
who appropriately broke the shared
silence by uttering the now in mortal
words boys that was a friggin beast
there have been significant moments
during the life of this Center both
happy moments like its opening in 1996
and visited from President Barack Obama
and sad but incredibly inspiring moments
like professor Randy Pasha's famous last
lecture that I know personally dr. koan
affected you very deeply and moments
that are forever indelibly etched in our
minds ladies and gentlemen these
beautiful banners that you see hanging
from our pillars and letters that will
adorn our walls dr. Cohen now that your
name will forever grace or a building
please no sir that the example that you
set all of us will strive to achieve and
from this moment on for all who enter no
matter how far from home they may be
they will never be alone because in the
cowan university center this will truly
be everyone's home away from home on
campus on behalf of the entire Carnegie
Mellon staff in Pittsburgh California
and around the world congratulations and
thank you dr. Cohen many issues matter
to our students there are many things I
could bring up but what I focused on was
a sound mind sound body philosophy and
the need to invest in a university
center in a different way now tonight my
10-year reunion from Carnegie Mellon I
can stand here proud to think about the
construction that is about to take place
that will forever change this university
center and in Dorne the name of the man
who is behind it all on behalf of all
alumni worldwide and all future students
of this great institution we thank you
for your commitment to the student body
we're truly proud to be Carnegie Mellon
alumni who went through this experience
with you a walk through the you
see is truly a glimpse into the inner
workings of the broader Carnegie Mellon
community to me it is fitting that we
are here today to dedicate the
university center to the presidency and
continuing legacy of dr. Cohen I have
only known dr. Cohen for two years
however my Carnegie Mellon experience
has been enriched as a result of my
interactions with him it's a great day
for the corn family and it's a great day
for Carnegie Mellon University Jerry
bunny halle Josh Solomon and Nathan
congratulations congratulations not only
for and thanks not only for your
sacrifices Jerry but the sacrifices of
your family president Samara died I say
for Jerry and also for mark Nordenberg
they never leave their passions behind
they never quit they just lose their
faculties what I want to do on behalf of
the board of trustees of carnegie mellon
university is to do this i hereby name
this building the Jared L cowan
university center in recognition of your
distinctive service and enormous
contributions that you have made as the
eighth president of this university
congratulations you're focused on me I
guess because you can only put one name
up there but if you feel good about the
last 16 years it's because of what the
university did what all those
administrators who warner hall and
around University of what the faculty
have achieved the fabulous students
we've had the Alumni the staff everybody
affiliated this universe it's marvelous
to be the guy that all of his praises
heaped on and it gets his name up on the
building but I know and you
should be mindful of the fact that what
was really celebrating is an era in this
University's history I can't thank you
enough for this incredible honor thank
you all for being here today and enjoy
having fun in Cohen or whatever you call
it thank you very very much
you